if you've been thinking about u.s.
politics and trying to make sense of it
for the last year or so you might have
hit on something like the following
three propositions one u.s. partisanship
has never been so bad before - for the
first time it's geographically
spatialized we're divided between the
coasts which want to look outwards and
the center of the country which wants to
look inwards and third there's nothing
we can do about it
I'm here today to say that all three of
these propositions all of which sound
reasonable are not true in fact our u.s.
partisanship goes all the way back to
the very beginning of the Republic it
was geographically spatialized in almost
eerily the same way that it is today
and it often has been throughout US
history and last and by far most
importantly we actually have an
extraordinary mechanism that's designed
to help us manage factional
disagreements and partisanship and that
technology is the Constitution and this
is a evolving subtly subtly designed
entity that has the specific purpose of
teaching us how to manage factional
disagreements where it's possible to do
that and giving us techniques for
overcoming that disagreement when that's
possible now in order to tell you the
story I want to go back to a pivotal
moment in US history and that is the
moment when factional disagreements and
partisanship was born
it actually was a birth mom oment in US
history when partisanship snapped into
place the person who is at the core of
that story
is james madison and at the moment that
this began james madison was writing hi
he himself was the Einstein of not only
the US Constitution but of
constitutional thought more globally and
to give him his view he knew it in a
period of time of just three years from
1785 to 1788 he had conceived theorized
designs past and gotten ratified the US
Constitution and just to give you some
sense of the enormity of what that
accomplishment actually was although
Madison couldn't have known it at the
time today that same constitutional
technology that he invented is still in
use not only in the u.s. by 230 years
later in places like Canada India South
Africa Brazil so an extraordinary range
of context all over the world this
technology is still the dominant most
used most effective technology to manage
governance now in that moment Madison
believed that having solved this problem
the country would run smoothly and he
had designed a technology that would
minimize the results of faction so there
would be no political parties remarkably
he thought he had designed a
constitution that was against political
parties and would make them unnecessary
and he had done an enormous degree of
help in the final marketing phase of his
constitutional project from a man you
may have heard of called Alexander
Hamilton now Hamilton was everything
Madison was not he was passionate where
Madison was restrained
he was pansexual where Madison didn't
speak to a woman except for once until
he was 42 years old and then marry dolly
and live happily ever after for 40 years
to put it bluntly Hamilton's the kind of
person about whom you would write a
hip-hop musical
and Madison is the kind of person about
whom you would not write a hip-hop
musical or indeed a musical of any kind
at all but together they had become a
rather unlikely pairing and they had
produced the Federalist Papers which
offered a justification and as I
mentioned a marketing plan for the
Constitution which had been wildly
effective effective and wildly
successful once the new government was
in place Hamilton became secretary of
the Treasury and he had a very specific
idea in mind and that was to do for
financial institutions and
infrastructure exactly what Madison had
done for constitutions again his
contemporaries all knew it one of them
told Madison who kind of liked it very
much that Hamilton was in Newton of
infrastructure and the idea was pretty
straightforward Hamilton would give the
United States a National Bank a
permanent national debt he said it would
be immortal his phrase and a
manufacturing policy that would enable
trade and manufacturing rather than
agriculture which was where the
country's primary wealth had
historically been Madison went utterly
ballistic and in this pivotal critical
decision instead of just telling the
world that his old friend Hamilton was
wrong and was adopting the wrong
policies he actually began to argue that
Hamilton's ideas were unconstitutional
that they violated the very nature of
the Constitution that the two of them
had drafted together
Hamilton responded the way you would
expect
he declared Madison to be his personal
and political enemy either his words so
these two founders who had been such
close friends and such close allies and
such partners then began to produce
enmity and they did it in the good
old-fashioned way first they founded
political parties
Madison created a party originally
called the Democratic Republican Party
Republican for short and Hamilton
created a party called a federalist
party and those two parties adopted
positions
on national politics they were extreme
and exaggerated to give you a clear
example Madison who had always believed
that the country would have some
manufacturing and some trade and some
agriculture began attacking Hamilton as
a kind of tool of the financial markets
whom Hamilton and himself intended to
put in charge of the country that was an
overstatement but it was something that
Madison came to believe he also attacked
city life and he said that the coasts
were corrupt and what people needed to
do was to look inwards to the center of
the country to farmers who were the
essence of Republican virtue and they
should go back to the values that had
made America great
specifically the values of the
Revolution and those were values of low
taxes agriculture and less trade
Hamilton responded to this by saying
that Madison was naive that he was
childish and that his goal was to turn
the United States into a primitive
autarky self-reliant and completely
ineffectual on the global scale
they both meant it and there was some
truth to each of their claims because
each side was grossly exaggerating the
views of the other in order to fight
their war they founded newspapers and so
for the first time in US history the
news that people received came entirely
through the lens of either the
Republican or the Federalist Party how
does this end well as it turned out the
Constitution did its work but it did its
work in surprising ways that Madison
himself had not fully anticipated first
there was a series of elections and the
first two times out of the box
the Federalists destroyed the
Republicans
Madison was astonished
of course he blamed the press
and in a rather innovative view Madison
never failed to innovate when he thought
about anything he said the reason that
the press was so Profeta list is that
the advertisers were all Federalists
because they were traders on the coasts
who got their capital from Britain which
federalism was in bed with that was his
initial explanation but despite the fact
that the Federalists once in power
actually enacted laws that criminalized
criticism of the government that
happened in the United States
nevertheless the Republicans fought back
and Madison began to emphasize the
freedom of speech which he had built
into the Bill of Rights and the capacity
of civil society to organize and sure
enough nationally small local groups
they were called Democratic Republican
societies began to form and protest
against Federalist dominated hegemony
eventually the Republicans managed to
win a national election that was in 1800
Madison became the Secretary of State
his friend and mentor Jefferson became
president and they actually over time
managed to put the Federalists
completely out of business that was
their goal now why did that happen
it happened because in the structure of
the Constitution were several features
that actually managed faction the way
they were supposed to do in the first
place
what were those one most important of
all the freedom of speech this was an
innovative idea at the time namely that
if you were out of power you could still
say that the government was terrible to
civil society organization the capacity
to put together private groups
individuals political parties and others
would organize to try to bring about
fundamental change perhaps most
significantly was the separation of
powers an extraordinary component of the
Constitution the thing about the
separation of power is
is that it did then and it does now
drive governance to the center you can
get elected to office in the United
States with help from the periphery
right or left it turns out you actually
can't govern unless you bring onboard
the center there are midterm elections
that come incredibly fast after a
presidency begins those drive presidents
towards the center there's a structure
in which the president in fact does not
rule or even govern but can only propose
laws which other people have to agree
with another feature the tends to drive
presidents who actually want to get
things done to the center and a glance
at the newspapers today will reveal to
you that these principles are still
completely in operation no matter how a
president gets elected the president
cannot get anything done unless the
president first of all follows the rules
of the Constitution because if not the
courts will stand up as indeed has
sometimes occurred not only recently but
in the past in US history and
furthermore the president needs people
elected officials who know they need to
win election from centrist voters also
to back his or her policies in order to
pass laws without it nothing much
happens the takeaway of this brief
excursus into the history of
partisanship then is the following
partisanship is real it's profound it's
extraordinarily powerful and it's
terribly upsetting but the design of the
Constitution is greater than
partisanship it enables us to manage
partisanship when that's possible and it
enables us actually to overcome partisan
division and produce compromise when and
only when that is possible
a technology like that is the technology
that worked for the founders it worked
for their grandchildren it didn't work
at the moment of the civil war but then
it started working again and it worked
for our grandparents our parents and
it's going to work for us so what you
should do is really simple stand up for
what you believe in support the
organizations that you care about speak
out on the issues that matter to you get
involved make change express your
opinion and do it with respect and
knowledge and confidence but it's only
by working together that the
constitutional technology can do the job
that it is designed to do stand up for
what you believe but take a deep breath
while you do it
it's going to be okay thanks
[Applause]